well what a change after a lot of
sunshine and an afternoon High near 80
yesterday let's see what's going on with
the official number out at Reed
International at this hour we've had
steady winds between 15 and 25 miles an
hour here we are with a temperature over
60 but the winds now gusting over 41
miles an hour and yes there is rain in
those clouds it's coming down over much
of Lincoln County trying to get down
here into Clark County as before it
moves into Southwestern Utah now this
area in light blue those are the wind
advisories the areas in red those are
high wind warnings or in some cases dust
warnings so your weather headlines go
like this the wind advisory for Las
Vegas for gusts over 40 the wind warning
for the higher elevations for gusts to
70 miles an hour and then the
temperature roller coaster is going to
be going up I don't know if you're going
to believe some of the numbers that we
have coming up for you for high
temperatures on the Easter Sunday that's
coming up in a few minutes Heather